voilà on va continuer avec la chronique
innovations et les maximes vous avez
choisi une ambiance intimiste entre nous
ce soir exactement une ambiance on
dirait de croiser bien oui c'est à
genoux comme dans le noir cépage de vous
apporter mes lumières en tout cas ne
vous inquiétez pas si vous nous plonge
dans le noir c'est pour vous êtes attiré
votre attention sur cet objet alors
qu'est ce que c'est que cet objet c'est
une minette que nous utilisons pour nos
pour nos reportages voilà les
téléspectateurs ne sont pas forcément
tous censé le savoir une minette à
l'aide
et pourquoi est-ce que je vous montre ça
il ne sait pas ce que j'ai envie de
faire ceci qu'est ce que je fais
exactement j'allume et jettent un jeu
créé un langage un langage binaire plus
précisément et un est égal à zéro
allumée est égal à 1
et bien ce langage binaire lumineux
pourrait bientôt remplacer le wifi car
c'est très sérieux
c'est vraiment crade rester sérieuse ray
dans le noir mais c'est une chronique
très sérieux ça s'appelle le visio
visible light communication s'est
développée par l'université versailles
saint quentin et je vous propose
d'écouter cédric meyer qui est un
professeur de l'ue vs qq qui va nous
expliquer en gros à quoi sert comment
fonctionne ce visible light
communication écouté par exemple sur de
l'audio vous avez donc un lecteur mp3 un
lecteur mp3 presse des données
merrick cdu 0 1 donc qu'est-ce qu'on va
faire on va faire comme unité ce qu'on
appelle l'éclairage à led
c'est comme si on était niée en allumer
à des fréquences très rapide ou à des
fréquences variés et du coup vous
véhiculez comme ça les informations les
données les héros de l'autre côté vous
avez un photorécepteurs héros transcode
hérode des codes cette information là
pour transformer ça en une musique c'est
exactement le même principe que sur du
wifi alors le même principe que le wifi
à une exception près d'un stade il n'y a
pas d' onde électromagnétique donc pas
de risque pour la santé
franchement ça marche très bien
voilà donc on transmet une information
par un parent langage c'est une voix
lasse taxer un code en fait finalement
c'est alors ça fonctionne très
simplement on va voir quelques images
qui vont apparaître tout de suite
donc on va voir donc là voilà il ya un
émetteur et un récepteur et regarder
écouter
alors si la main passe devant la lumière
la musique
c'est un la musique une base plus la
clad inquiéter thébaux sinon temps plein
ok c'est clair d'un côté on a un
émetteur de l'autre côté on a un
récepteur et la musique circule par les
ondes par le spectre lumineux alors on
peut faire la même chose avec de la
vidéo vous allez voir ça tout de suite
également en images et par pareil cas
voilà si on a la caméra est relié donc à
une carte de ce qu'on appelle car c'est
très bien c'est avec mayer les la petite
vidéo avec est en train d'enregistrer le
film et ensuite les informations sont
envoyées via le kbis annoncé le langage
binaire qui envoie sa avons eu en main
une lampe qui est con statut de l'aide
comme les petites landes alors on avait
tout à l'heure en plateau il ya à
nouveau la photo ça arrive sur ce
récepteur est ensuite c'est retransmis à
l'écran c'est donc magique
c'est surprenant et donc s'est
développée en fait par une start up
alors cette start up c'est elle et ça
veut dire qu'il faut toujours avoir une
lampe à proximité pour diffuser la
lumière alors points oui il faut savoir
sur les glorieuses c'est très important
il faut une source lumineuse alors ça
peut être une source où les délais que
des lamas petites ampoules de tout à
l'heure avec non celle là non ça va nous
l'avons fait mais c'est vraiment des
leds parce que en fait le principe avec
les lettres sait qu'on peut les allumés
et les éteindre
jusqu'à un milliard de fois par seconde
donc c'est autant de combinaisons
d'extinction et d'allumage qui sont
possibles en fait c'est infini quoi donc
c'est à dire qu'en gros on peut
transférer ses 1 gigabit par par seconde
donc c'est quand même énorme
d'information 7 tab aux délits fichiers
vidéos fichiers photos textes
alors pour l'instant la seule chose
qu'on peut pas faire c'est s'est envoyé
est renvoyée ça pour l'instant ça ne
fonctionne que dans un seul sens ça que
la à terme l'objectif du laboratoire qui
développe ce système qui est donc un
laboratoire de l'université versailles
saint quentin
l'objectif c'est de pouvoir utiliser ça
pour internet et donc internet ça
implique des échanges et donc pour
l'instant il n'ya pas qu'on les change
comparativement la cds et c'est est-ce
que complètement on peut voir une
réalisation pourrait envisager une
réalisation des sociétés qui se sont
l'intéressé alors il ya des socialistes
qui se sont très intéressés il ya la
sncf par exemple sncf qui actuellement
vous savez que quand on prend le train
il n'y a pas de wifi disponibles déjà on
a du mal à voir la 3g la 4g on en parle
dans certaines régions de france mais
pour l'instant on n'en voit pas la
couleur
donc pourquoi pas le wifi et wifi coûte
extrêmement cher à développer donc cette
start-up harwich je vais peut-être
clarifier la situation je vous parle de
start up je vous parlais malabo le
parcours en fait ce qui s'est passé
c'est que ce sont des chercheurs d'un
laboratoire de l'ue vs qui ont créé une
start-up une start up dans laquelle
l'université versailles saint quentin a
investi des fonds cercle à sur cinq ans
et à 5000 euros aux actionnaires d'une
start up
voilà exactement et donc il est en fait
là on passe en phase de
commercialisation et donc je vous le
disais donc la sncf est intéressé à dire
que bientôt peut-être que grâce à ce
système on pourra utiliser nos tablettes
nos téléphones aux smartphones jeu pour
pas citer de marque dans les transports
en commun grâce à la lumière c'est à
dire que les transports en commun c'est
un environnement parfait pour s'amuser
aussi les intérêts s'est amusé en france
notamment
il est à montréal hiver là il va être
ouvert au mois d'avril
2013 il s'agit du musée grévin c'est
exactement la même chose que celui qu'on
a à paris sauf que ça va être un
montréal il ya une commande pour quatre
cent mille euros qui a été qui était
faite auprès de cette start up pour des
tablettes des tablettes en fait le
système on va voir quelques images aussi
c'est très simple si un peu quand on
arrive devant une statue
il ya une lumière qui est juste au
dessus de la statue voilà et l envoi ou
une information à la tablette
l'utilisateur n'a rien à faire c'est à
dire que contrairement aux une fois que
tu es tu sors de ça s'arrête
et donc on passe à une autre lumière est
faite contrairement aux audioguides vous
connaissez les audioguides le
principalement donne à l'entrée des
musées on est obligé de sélectionner une
une piste avec un numéro en fonction de
la salle dans laquelle on arrive et ben
là c'est pas le cas du tout c'est
vraiment complètement intuitif
complètement instinctif n'y a pas besoin
de connaître quoi que ce soit cela que
même les enfants par exemple qui ne
savent pas lire peuvent utiliser ce type
de tablette on arrive on se ballade pop
up et puis il ya un contenu qui
s'affichent près ce que je retiens c'est
que c'est bon pour la santé parce qu'il
n'ya pas donc il n'ya pas de
l'électromagnétisme tels sont seulement
voilà si au niveau de justement au
niveau santé au niveau des technologies
qui servent comme ça envoyer des données
à distance
on a le bluetooth pour l'instant le wifi
et l'infrarouge le wifi ondes
électromagnétiques infrarouge faible
portée on pourrait pousser la porte est
un peu plus mais le problème c'est ça
commencera à devenir dangereux pour les
yeux puisque l infrarouge c'est bien le
principe c'est qu'on ne le voit pas
enfin le l'humain ne ne le voit pas et
le bluetooth des ondes également donc
finalement le 20 avril a été communiquée
shon qui est développé en france a levé
ce qui pourrait être une solution pour
faire communiquer les appareils entre
eux et donc les gens non mais ça va
super beau cocorico voilà encore écho
voilà une innovation française est une
illusion saint-quentinoise merci maxime
pour cette chronique elle est on va plus
on va partir maintenant à la rencontre
peut-être de futurs ingénieurs allez
savoir en tout cas pour l'instant ce ne
sont que des nouveaux nés direction la
maternité de poissy qui accueilli
pendant un mois les 50 caméras de
l'émission baby boom dont la deuxième
saison est diffusée ce soir sur tf1
lohan aurait pu participer au programme
baby boom
ce petit tiny montain d'à peine une
heure est né à la maternité de poissy
c'est dans ce service que les caméras de
tf1 se sont installés pendant un mois
pour filmer la deuxième saison de baby
boom
un programme à mi chemin entre
documentaire et télé-réalité la caméra
source ou fixe on va te sont installés
en avançant dans le service ce qui fait
qu'on n'a jamais aucun caméraman en visu
donc ça que c'est une technique a priori
et utilisait beaucoup dans la télé
réalité mais qui permet essentiellement
là dans l'hôpital d'être complètement
seul avec les patients c'est linguae
sage femme à l'hôpital de poissy depuis
cinq ans elle a participé à la première
saison de baby boom suivi par 2 millions
et demi de téléspectateurs
on n'avait jamais vu le travail de
sages-femmes de cette façon là ça
permettait de voir bas que quand même
pas que l'accouchement il y avait aussi
tout l'encadrement des couples je crois
que cette première saison elle était
bien aussi parce qu'elle permettait de
voir ce qui se passe dans une salle de
naissance quand on ne l'est pas donc
professionnels de santé ce qui se passe
entre le père la mère et puis après les
avec le bébé et que c'était au plus
proche en fait de l'émotion vraiment
ressentie par les gens c'est un travail
sur l'émotion autour de la naissance
l'émotion des parents
l'émotion des professionnels et leur
travail leur travail en équipe
50 caméras dissimulées en salle
d'accouchement aux urgences ou encore en
réanimation des nouveau nés
pour suivre au plus près la couche man 2
65 maman et le travail d'une dizaine de
sages femmes
on a donc des patientes qui nous sont
attribués à chacune chacune a ses
patientes
et puis on suit le travail en cours de
chaque de chaque dame ont fait les
accouchements on récupère le bébé des
césariennes programmées
on s'occupe des enfants qui sont nés et
des patientes en fonction des
différentes façons d'accoucher sur les
65 femmes volontaires seuls noms
figureront dans le programme dont
l'intégralité des épisodes a été
visionné par françoise damageux très
impliqué depuis la première saison que
ce soit dans la première saison où dans
la deuxième on avait un droit de regard
c'est à dire qu'on était deux personnes
moi même et un des médecins de l'équipe
nous avons visionné l'ensemble des
épisodes nous avions uniquement un droit
de regard sur le niveau déontologique
secret médical
céline elle n'a pas encore visionné la
nouvelle saison de baby boom la
sage-femme découvrira en même temps que
les téléspectateurs le premier épisode
sur tf1 mardi 18 septembre à 23h15